hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion on October 16th 2023 a young man
looked around the courtroom nervously he
made eye contact with his ex-girlfriend
Caroline Ellison she was about to
testify and expose the dark depths of
his deception with every word that came
out of her mouth his whole world began
to collapse and by the end of her
statement he was finished just a year
ago he was the darling of the
cryptocurrency world his company was
worth $32 billion
but now that was all gone he was now
facing seven charges and up to 115 years
in prison the scene I'm describing is of
course the trial of Sam bankman freed if
you've been following this channel for a
little while you would have seen my
piece on the multi-billion dollar FTX
collapse it really was an unbelievable
story of how a group of ragtag kids
could engineer a fraud so large that
they bought themselves government
influence today we'll take a look at the
court
case you are watching Fusion
TV so to bring everyone up to speed a
quick recap FTX was a cryptocurrency
exchange and hedge fund it was founded
in 2019 by Sam bankman freed AKA s SPF
his then girlfriend Caroline Ellison was
in charge of alam research a trading
house Sam would insist that these two
companies were separate entities but
behind the scenes FTX was using customer
funds and giving them to Alam research
and these customer funds were
squandered from its Inception FTX
funneled consumer deposits into bank
accounts owned or managed by
Alam according to the Department of
Justice and SEC bankman freed also
personally borrowed more than $1 billion
from Alam again this was all funded by
FTX customers he also approved similar
loans to his parents and FTX Executives
but on the surface
everything was perfect FTX was growing
quickly in size and by 2021 they had
celebrity endorsements a Stadium named
after them and Sam himself was even
mixing with
politicians in September of 2022
Bloomberg reported the close ties
between FTX and Alam then on November
2nd of 2022 coind Des published an
article that exposed that 5.8 billion
out of the 14.6 billion of assets on the
balance sheets of alam research were
linked to an FTX crypto token that was
made out of thin air I've covered the
full story of this in the previous
episode but long story short this
triggered a massive selloff of people
trying to get their money out in the end
FTX couldn't pay back their customers as
their deposits were loan to Alam
essentially FTX users couldn't withdraw
their fund and the company would file
for bankruptcy on November 11th 2022 a
month later Sam bankman freed was
arrested in the Bahamas where FTX was
headquartered and then he was extradited
to the US he was placed under house
arrest but was taken into custody in
August okay so let's talk about the
trial on the 3rd of October SPF began
his trial at a court in New York there
are going to be two trials but the
second will be in March 20124 as for the
charges on the first trial there're
essentially multiple counts of wire
fraud and moneya
laundering the United States government
is accusing s SPF and his friends of
misappropriating consumer funds and
giving it to Alam research they were
lying to Consumers lenders and investors
which amounts to fraud s SPF was also
accused of being the leader of the
scheme so we all know that billions in
consumer funds disappeared and that was
only highlighted when people panicked
and all tried to get their money out of
FTX all at once but where did the money
go well s SPF either lost it in Risky
Investments Acquisitions debt servicing
making loans to himself and others
A-list celebrity endorsements marketing
campaigns and of course political
donations according to the courts
bankman freed spent $100 million in
political contributions and bought a $40
million Penthouse where he and other FTX
Executives lived the loans were also
used to buy luxury Jets and the SEC
claims that these transactions were
quote at times not documented at all the
hope is that 90% of these funds will
eventually be recovered and return to
the
victims during the trial SPF and the
defense made him out to be an overworked
young businessman that was just trying
to do the right thing he simply just
made a few mistakes maybe his risk
management wasn't perfect but he never
purposefully tried to defraud anyone he
said that he didn't know that the funds
of FTX customers were being misused
until just before the collapse Sam's
defense team blamed his ex-girlfriend
for the bankruptcy of of both companies
emphasizing her ineptitude and failure
to hedge alam's Financial positions but
unfortunately for Sam his ex-friend
Caroline would sing like a bird and
destroy him Caroline Ellison the CEO of
alam research and the ex-girlfriend of
Sam was about to testify there was no
one better positioned and no one closer
to Sam she was the perfect person to
shed light on his
actions the pair of them would meet at
Jane Street a trading firm where they
both worked after colle
Caroline took to the stand she was asked
to point out Sam in the crowd and
describe what he was wearing he's over
there wearing a
suit yes that's right for today Sam had
ditched his trademark black T-shirt and
cargo shorts for a gray suit and purple
tie in the
courtroom the prosecutor Danielle suon
asked Caroline quote when you were
working at Alam did you commit any
crimes Ellison replied yes we did suon
continues quote when you say we who do
you mean by we Caroline I mean Sam and I
and others fraud conspiracy to commit
fraud and moneya laundering suon did you
commit these crimes alone Ellison
replied no they were committed with Sam
Caroline Ellison would go on to say that
the decision to use FTX consumer funds
to cover alam's losses was quote Sam's
decision interestingly in the court
hearing she also mentioned that Sam
wanted to become the president of the
United States Someday I'm sure that
would have been interesting she would
also go on to testify about how
important Sam's image was including
specifically his hair Sam once stated
quote I honestly think it's negative
estimated value for me to cut my hair I
think it's important for people to think
I look crazy Sam's attorney would later
hilariously State quote there was a time
when Sam was probably the worst dressed
CEO in the world and had the worst
haircut but that's not a crime end quote
in the end Ellison pleaded guilty to
seven criminal charges including wire
fraud Securities fraud and money
laundering she also admitted to giving
her parents a $100,000
loan Barbara freed and Joseph bankman
are Sam's parents and ironically they're
both professors of get this legal ethics
at Stanford law it's suspected that
their expertise reputation and
connections helped FTX seem legitimate
at least in the beginning Sam's parents
attended almost every day of the trial
and were close advisers to Sam Sam even
previously referred to FTX as quote a
family business at one point during the
court case it was revealed that at least
Sam's dad is a piece of work in a
revealed Email exchange he complained
that being paid $200,000 for advertising
FTX was a pittance quote G Sam I don't
don't know what to say here this is the
first I have heard of a 200k a year
salary putting Barbara on this end quote
that was written to his son in January
of 2022 Sam seemingly listened to his
parents and less than 2 weeks later they
received $10 million from Alam research
and a $10 million Bahamas
property during the court case a major
problem for Sam was that he just didn't
keep his mouth shut before his arrest
the FTX founder did a string of
high-profile media interviews he
appeared on podcasts and tweeted
incessantly and in the courtroom the
comments that he would make during these
interviews came back to haunt him during
his cross-examination time and time
again the prosecution would refer to
incriminating statements that Sam gave
during these media tours they would ask
Sam so did you say the statement and Sam
would always say I don't remember and
then the prosecution would show evidence
of him saying that exact thing Paul
tuchman a former prosecutor sums it up
perfectly if there's anything for
bankman freed to regret it is not the
decision to testify but the public
statements he made before his arrest he
made it significantly easier for the
prosecution he made his bed now he lying
in
it Sam bankman freed got demolished in
the courtroom he stood up to hear what
the jury had decided in only a matter of
hours
they found him guilty on all counts once
the verdict was read he sat back down
with no emotion his parents on the other
hand appeared distraught according to
Wired Magazine quote s spf's Father
Joseph bankman leaned forward holding
his hands on the side of his head his
mother Barbara freed clutched her hands
to her
face before long they were holding one
another it was over for SPF he was
whisked away way and he took one last
look at his parents only giving a small
resigned nod of acknowledgement and with
that he was
gone Sam bankman freed faces up to 115
years in prison is he going to get that
much time I doubt it although the
founder of FTX will be sentenced on
March 28th 2024 so we'll have to wait
and see at least for the moment he's
going to remain incarcerated in Brooklyn
New York at the Metropolitan Detention
Center
Sam bankman freed was seen as the most
responsible man in crypto his exchange
FTX was a sure bet extremely safe he was
even poised to start writing the rule
book for crypto regulation he testified
before Congress multiple times had close
connections to lawmakers in part thanks
to $100 million in political donations
but now he's one of the most famous
criminals of the
2020s and with that that is where we
stand on the Sam bankman freak case
so thanks for watching feel free to
check out the previous episode on this
all right I'll see you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
[Music]
one cold fusion it's new thinking